[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get to uh
wright thompson espn senior writer
let's make pappy land the uh best seller
list on new york
times the story of family fine bourbon
and other things that last
available online wherever books are sold
i never steer you wrong when i tell you
about uh a great book and uh this is a
great book it's just
it's a great read it feels like it's
supposed to be about bourbon but it's
really about
family father son and uh wright thompson
joins us on the program how did i do how
did i
do with selling that well i think you
did well like rush
you know obviously i don't care about
being on the top ten but we're both
lying
uh the i feel like a rush show is like a
grateful dead show that isn't fun
like like i don't know that for sure
but no look i uh
now i appreciate that it's uh uh you
know we've we've joked before my wife
makes fun of me saying i didn't eat pray
love for dads but
i mean it you know it is it is
ostensibly the story of
uh of julian van winkle making the
rarest bourbon in the world but i mean
as you alluded to
it in an accident this accidentally
happened sort of
it turned into a story about julian and
his dad
and his children and the story about me
and my dad and my two daughters and
uh because it ends up being a meditation
on inheritance and on home and family
and sort of the things that we want to
pass down to our kids and the things
that we don't
uh you know i think you know you and i
have talked about that before but i mean
it's
it is trying to unravel those things if
you were going to
give a bourbon 101 to our audience
what to look for the tape you know
because can be pretty intimidating when
you walk into a liquor store and you're
going
i have no idea what i'm buying here do
you know enough about
bourbon after hanging out with uh pappy
van winkle that you could give some
advice
i mean the thing i learned is sort of
counterintuitive to what you would think
after all that time around him
which is one there there's no wrong
answer
so like whatever it is that you like for
whatever reason you like
is great i mean there's so many brands
out there almost all of the whiskey
comes from six or seven distilleries
you know i get these emails all the time
from people who bought pappy land and
are like well you know
my buddy's getting married or you know
what bottle of whiskey should i get
and my standard answer is go get a
really nice crystal decanter and fill it
up with maker's marker wild turkey
because you know i don't you know the
point is
the whiskey and one of the things i
write about in the book a lot is coming
to understand that
the whiskey is the vehicle for the thing
it isn't the thing itself
it is the conversation it is the people
you're with it is the people who were
once there who were now there
only in the sort of spirit of the toast
and
that matters more to me at least and to
julian
than however many points it got in some
competition
yeah because you can go into a store in
fact i went into a store a couple of
days ago
and i just love to pick their brain i
always say
what what is it that everybody wants and
why do they want it
and it and it comes down to supply and
demand and people should know
that happy van winkle is very expensive
on the secondary market
and and that the owner julian doesn't
make that money and it feels like
i think in in the book people would come
up to him they're they're angry at him
like why is your bourbon so expensive
well it's funny because people are
always asking why don't you
make more and he always says because i'm
not selling it to you i'm selling it to
your children
and i don't know what they're going to
like i don't want to make a bunch of
this stuff that comes out in 20 years
and find out that the trend has changed
i mean one of the things i found
fascinating about being around julian
and about working on the book was that
he has to live 12 15 20 23 years in the
future
and that sort of accidentally bleeds
into
other parts of his life like you start
to find it really seductive
because you think well could i live like
that you know i work for a cable news
network you know i mean there is no
tomorrow past the next 30 seconds and
julian
is 20 years out i mean the whiskey
they're putting in barrels right now he
won't live to see
bottled and so one of the things i
thought that was really
fascinating about spending time with him
was both listening to him talk about
that but also just
watch how that bled into how he orders
his life
he's right thompson the book is papi
lynn a story of family fine bourbon
and the things that last it's available
online wherever books
are sold give me the person you profiled
that you'd like to do a follow-up on
i mean i'd like to go evidently and if
somebody knows
more about this please reach out to me
but evidently michael jordan is becoming
a really good marlin fisherman
and i'm yeah you know i remember richard
ben cramer's famous piece about ted
williams
and how serious fishermen respected ted
williams
not because he was famous but because he
was good at the thing
and i'm curious how good michael is
getting at that and how
into it he's getting i mean you know is
it just something to go do while you
drink beer or has this
activated the lizard brain and the name
of his boat which evidently he came up
with i love is catch23
which is a great fishing boat name like
i'm just like
oh michael the uh but
i i would be interested to know if that
is a hobby or if it has
entered the realm of obsession and you
do these deep dives you did a wonderful
one with pat riley
it all it just feels like there's
interconnected tissue with
a lot of these marquee people in
in what they do and how they do it and
why they do it um
or or am i reading too much into that
right
well i think one i think there are only
like six stories
you know that happen over and over and
over again i mean i love just to sort of
sit back and laugh
like fathers and sons man you know we
think we're so complicated and we're
just
not and you know i mean it's it's all
there right below the surface
so i mean i've spent a lot of time
wondering i don't know if you have but
like is there a greatness gene
like if michael jordan would have been
introduced to
swimming or to chess like was he going
to be great at whatever first
activated his mind i mean you and i
talked about that a couple years ago
about tiger woods i mean if someone
would
if earl woods would have handed tiger
woods a cello would he have been
yo-yo ma and i don't really know the
answer to that but there do
seem to be points of connection with
these people who are super high
achievers
are those people ever satisfied though
i don't know usually not that's what you
know you and i have talked about dale
murphy who is the happiest retired ball
player i've ever met
and i think that it's because the people
who are happy
understand that the famous version of
them
has only a passing
similarity with the actual them and that
that
you have to like somehow let that person
go i think the people who are happiest
are the ones
who don't you know is that famous john
updike quote the mask eats the face i
think the people who are happiest are
the ones
who are self-aware enough to know that
that is probably going to happen and try
to stop it
what are you working on now i'm doing a
thing about manchester united
that is uh that is roaring along
uh it's uh i can't really talk about it
but i've been uh brainstorming a uh
a thing with mickey heart from the
grateful dead uh 16 year old me his mind
is blown
to get an email from michael hart so
that's pretty incredible
uh are you in england now no i just got
home i'm in laurel mississippi i had a
book event last night oh okay
uh uh but no i i got home i don't know
sunday
i don't even know what day it is and uh
but you can't tell me what the
manchester united oh sure
sure and well so what's what's it's
nominally about the super league
which i'm sure you guys have talked
about on the show and but what's
interesting is
i wanted to write about the 150 year arc
of man united fans as a way of
showing both who the people were who
were really angry
about this and how they got so angry and
uh you know i really like places where
the membrane between the past and the
present is really thin
you know manchester you know the
birthplace of the industrial revolution
there they were these neighborhoods just
north of the city center where all the
cotton mills were
and that was forever the heartlands of
man united supporters
and the same forces of globalism that
were invented
in those factories where their ancestors
worked are now at work on
soccer and everything else football to
them apologies if you're in manchester
and it was interesting to me that what
you're really watching
is a business decoupling from one group
of parochial local
fans and recoupling to a large
global audience of consumers and so all
of the stress and the tension
and the angst that you feel in
manchester feels connected to those
really old
forces that are just beneath the surface
have you
uh taken a deep dive into music with
with a profile i mean i know that i've
known you
with all the things you've done sports
wise but i'm curious about
that musical genius that we see
and is it applicable to like bruce
springsteen strikes me as a
perfectionist and driven
to whatever lengths to continue to prove
himself
but i don't know if you've done any
profiles
i have not i would like to because i do
think there are some similarities
i mean i think specifically with with
bruce
uh i mean when you go i like to listen
to those records in order
because they all feel like letters from
a certain time in his life
and one of the things i think is
probably different is that an athlete
is great by suppressing that
self-knowledge
and i think if you're going to be bruce
springsteen you have to be
hyper self-aware if you're gonna put out
these documents that are based on your
own life
that feel true to the listener and so i
think that
there it's interesting that i think
they're probably a lot of the same
traits but i bet musicians to be great
have to access insecurities and doubts
that
athletes have to deny and repress i mean
i don't know i've never really thought
about it until now but i mean i
imagine that there's similarities but
also those things feel very different
i wish you luck with the book and uh
hopefully we'll uh
make it now do you want to be number one
on the new york times
bestseller or just on the best selling
well well how about where
uh what was led zeppelin with a whole
lot of love
do we know paulie do we know where a
whole lot of love ended up
i should know this my favorite band i
got it as uh it was once eight
on the charts you know what eight eight
sounds great i mean by the way the fact
that
uh when the levee breaks wasn't the
number one song in the world
is just utterly baffling to me
i mean get out come on who's voting on
this stuff uh
i i think it's just people buying it is
that right paulie
that's it just billboard rankings amazon
purchases so
we did that to led zeppelin
collectively what's interesting so what
was number one sorry i we're way off the
track what was number one when this was
number eight
paulie do you have billboard the top ten
list when zeppelin was eight
yeah i i do actually i want you back by
the jackson five
well that's pretty good that's a good
song what was two venus
shocking blue i don't know that
raindrops keep falling in my head bj
thomas okay
he just passed away i'm correcting it
now if i confirmed a whole lot of love
was number four that week
oh okay okay what was three uh raindrops
keep falling ahead
uh that's a good list don't cry daddy by
elvis was six
come on sly in the family stone was
number eight
sly underrated slime family stone
underrated
uh hey good luck with the book always
great to talk to you right thank you
buddy
he's uh wright thompson the book is papi
lana's story of family fine bourbon
and things that last if you want to
learn about bourbon
you'll learn that but it's also about
father
son family relationship and a great
father's day gift